you stated that the NIH has not ever and  has not now fund gain of function  research in the Wuhan Institute of  virology  and yet  gain of function research was done  entirely in the Wuhan Institute by Dr  she and was funded by the NIH senator  Paul I have never lied before the  Congress and I do not retract that  statement and senator Paul you do not  know what you are talking about quite  frankly and I want to say that  officially the grant that was funded as  a sub award from Eco Health to Wuhan  created saws cov2 that's where you are  getting let me finish we don't know wait  a minute I came to the lab but all the  evidence is pointing that it came from  the lab there will be responsibility for  those who funded the lab including  yourself well how she's not exactly  saying they didn't do it anymore right  he's just saying the funding may have  went to something else that was like  sort of ancillarially involved